prisons are becoming America's biggest
old people's homes
now the country that looks up more
people than anywhere else must deal with
the consequences of agreeing prison
population growing old in prison is hard
you know they just struggle with the
reality of just you know being in prison
they don't believe they're in prison
they don't know why they're in prison
that's the biggest struggle I see most
of the guys you know Samuel Baxter is an
inmate here at the California men's
colony prison in San Luis Obispo almost
everyday for the past four years mr.
Baxter has helped elderly prisoners get
dressed eat and get about prison it is a
confronting job he was the only
gentleman about 70 and I should take him
over to the clinic to get his insulin
shot so I remember one morning I came
down and he was standing in the sale and
I think he had a shoe at his hand and he
just added a bit of floor crying you
know and I tapped on the door I called
him by his name and he just looked at me
and he was like what am I doing here in
America some 2.2 million people are
behind bars and the prisoners are
getting older the number of people over
the age of 65 who were in prison has
doubled since 2007 in fact aging men and
women are the most rapidly growing part
of America's prison population in part
this is the hangover effect of the 1980s
and 90s when a perfect storm of high
crime rates and tough sentencing laws
caused prison populations to soar
I've been a part of that growing
population of elderly so I see it all
the time Phillip verdict is 64 he works
alongside mr. Baxter in a program called
the gold coats the volunteer inmates who
become gold coats are carefully screened
and shadow an experienced volunteer
sometimes for several months of training
older prisoners often have special needs
some have problems with mobility others
dementia or mental health
dr. steed is one of the supervisors of
the program from a physical standpoint
they're challenged many of them develop
motor difficulties as they get older we
have a hard time for a lot of them to go
up and down the stairs to the dining
hall many of our elderly patients also
experience difficulties with dementia
and difficulty with memory and that's
challenging for them from the standpoint
of not remembering what the routine is
not remembering what the rules are for
the institution and not remembering
simple things like when they have an
appointment that they need to get to a
showing he's doing he's the one day
caring for the elderly behind bars
presents unique challenges prisoners can
have the physiological age of someone 10
to 15 years older enemies tend to age
faster I think the individuals out in
the community in part because of the
high stress of the environment it's a
constant watching your back kind of
process where they have to keep an eye
out for other inmates and what's going
on and are they you know vulnerable in
some way as soon as you can't take care
of yourself you're a victim and there
are predators that will take advantage
of that Glenn Crites has been in prison
for 44 years since he was 20 years old
for murder he remembers catching another
elderly prisoner nicknamed pops staring
at him somebody introduced us and he
kept looking at me like he was mad dog'
we call it mad dog and he was looking at
me like you know who the hell are you
and I was taking offense to it pops had
Alzheimer's he was trying to remember
who mr. Critz was and in prison little
gestures will get you in trouble he
didn't fight Pop's but older inmates are
more vulnerable than younger ones when
we do is go coaches we you know we
protect them because we around when the
seals not around you know we see more
than officers see you know cuz we down
here with him like all day long
just making sure they okay of the 1.6
million inmates in state and federal
prisons 1/10 are serving life sentences
many politicians are now keen to reverse
this mass incarceration but long timers
seem unlikely to benefit in California a
bid to reduce prison populations means
less serious criminals now serve time in
county jails or in the community
the inmates left behind tend to be the
ones serving longer sentences these are
often the elderly America spends about
16 billion dollars every year caring for
older inmates the gold coats program
aims to allay some of those costs
volunteers are paid a mere 36 dollars a
month a fraction of what outside help
like a nursing assistant would cost the
prison and it's tough work a lot of the
inmates appreciate what we do was a lot
of them don't and here if your router or
snitch or something there that stigma
you get that stigma on you and then you
can have some serious consequences so
there's always that sort of danger
despite the challenges the gold coats
continue to help their aging
counterparts mr. Baxter has a
particularly personal reason for wanting
to do so his mother had dementia well
she came up to see me she was just as
little quiet lady she didn't say
anything she just said to him just
looked at me and smiled you know and I
was like okay so what's going on my
sister was like she's just only
membership
you know when I look at these guys under
give my mother what if she was in a
facility like that you know how would I
want her careful mr. Baxter is serving
35 years to life in prison for fatally
shooting a man he had his first parole
hearing in March but was turned down he
won't receive another review for at
least five years and he has come to
realize the gold codes may one day be
caring for him if I'm still incarcerated
you know when I'm in my 70s or 80s if
I'm still alive you know and I get to
the point to where you know I started
declining losing my memory I hope I'm a
part of a program like this because I
know it's gonna be a group of guys it's
gonna care for me make sure that my
knees are meant for the elderly men who
are released after decades behind bars
there may no longer be any friends or
family on the outside who can provide
care I think many times nursing
facilities are a little hesitant to take
on a parolee just because they're afraid
or they're worried about what sort of
behavior could could happen or the
person doesn't have the funds to pay for
you know a nursing facility so I think
unfortunately many of them are left with
you know where do I go how am I going to
support myself what are one of my
options when they get out not everyone
here will be granted parole some of
these men will die in prison I don't
think people a lot of people realize how
tough it is for a person to be in prison
and think that they're never going to
get out and they're going to die in here
for those nearing the end of their lives
mr. Burdick serves as a grief counselor
in the prison hospice program we helped
them to by just being there you know so
that nobody dies alone in prison